all right today we're going to talk
about wine wine can be very snobby can
get very highbrow it doesn't have to
specifically we're going to talk about a
rating line so here we have a bottle of
wine and here we have a decanter now the
Romans pioneered glass use of decanters
and there were a few purposes the first
was you would take let's say an old
bottle or an unfiltered bottle of wine
pour it right in here and that would
ideally leave the sediment in this
bottle so then you could get clean wine
from this the other reason people now
still use decanters is to expose the
wine to air to let it breathe and
there's a lot of other fancy terms but
many people find that it softens the
tannins that's that so that mouthfeel
that sometimes gives you a over brewed
tea type of taste or effect sensation
some people find it softens it so with a
Bordeaux for example Cabernet Sauvignon
some of these big wines with lots of
tannins and sometimes sulfites this is
what people will do the objective of
course is to expose it to more air so
the surface area is increased turns out
there are a few different ways to do
this if you decant wine like this you
might want to leave it out for an hour
two hours three hours well there are a
few other options that we have the first
is this venturi device and this
capitalizes on Bernoulli's principle
that just means that as you increase in
effect the velocity of liquid the
movement of liquid you decrease the
pressure and you're able to actually
infuse more air and this is what it
looks like so you would actually do it
right over a glass and being careful not
to pour it everywhere you can hear it
being siphoned through and increasing
the flow so this is a faster way it's a
cheat versus the larger decanter you can
do this over each glass so I'll just
take a sniff and you can get fancy this
is also one of the methods obviously by
swirling that you can also achieve
aerating but on a very minimal level any
excuse to have wine quite nice but if we
want to take this to its logical extreme
we can do what
Nathan Myhrvold recommence and now
Nathan was the former CTO or is the
former CTO of Microsoft and he's a bit
obsessive with food a master French chef
himself he has taken a slightly more
extreme approach so here we have and I
love these this is a Boehm X beaker and
it can be used for many many different
purposes we're going to pour a bunch of
wine in here I would suggest starting
off with about that much and we are
going to expose it to as much air as
possible using an immersion blender this
is also known as a stick blender this is
a Cuisinart Smart stick do not stick
your fingers into it but we will see
that you stick it in not all the way
you're not going to touch the bottom
entirely and you will do this for
20 to 30 seconds
you can see it's quite frothy here more
like Guinness than a typical glass of
wine you can even hear it and I like to
use the Boehm X to drink out of this is
actually 250 milliliters which is
exactly 1/3 a standard bottle of wine so
we can transfer this over markedly
different so there you have it that is
three hours of decanting achieved in 20
seconds with an immersion blender Thank
You mr. verbal